all right let's jump into this first
story we got this from the daily mail
elon musk tells twitter he is
terminating his 44 billion dollar
takeover because the company misled him
on the number of spam bots on site as
stocks plunged six percent
i just gotta say elon musk is right uh
look when twitter came out and said it
was like what did it say five percent or
something yeah
a whole bunch of there was there were
several different independent
assessments that they were like no way
that's way wrong
five percent is like the number of real
accounts right
i i saw a tweet that i think was from
paul scalise that was saying uh there's
like at most a hundred thousand people
on twitter i honestly may be true yeah
obviously i think it's i think it's
maybe several million maybe tens of
millions but not hundreds of millions i
think it's all one big i'd go with tens
of millions tens of millions yeah and
you can you know you know you know you
know what makes me think so
donald trump on truth social has 3.4
million
and you look at the engagement it's
comparable
he posts a truth and he gets you know
thousands of comments it was the same
when he was on twitter i'm like how
could it be the engagement stays the
same but the total following count is
way lower most people don't care
now the question is
is elon musk playing 4d chess
because look he's got a contract right
he can't just back out right people
people don't get this
i see these lefties posting like oh
elon's gonna have to pay a billion
dollars now and i'm like oh because
that's how lawsuits work right these
people have clearly never dealt with
legal system
someone could could smash into your car
and it could be their fault and you
could be in court for years trying to
figure that stuff out so what usually
happens is your lawyer says just saddle
with him it's so much easier make it go
away the judges often will tell you find
a settlement agreement so i've had to
deal with this stuff the judge will say
yeah we can go to court we can litigate
all this stuff i'm instructing you to to
attempt the settlement first
so what i think is going to happen
for one let's just be simple don't get
your hopes up elon might just be backing
out maybe he wasn't serious
or maybe start what was that i knew it
from the start
had a bad feeling about it yes
but maybe
we've been hearing for months that elon
wanted a a better offer a better deal
yeah because the stock had been going
down for twitter so it was like it was
worth less and less and less
so he probably went to his financiers
and they were like you can get it
cheaper
just give let it stew
the stock's gonna couldn't gonna drop
because the market
you can back away and twitter will still
save money by just agreeing to lower
terms
as opposed to going to court and trying
to win a billion dollars from you so
that could be it because the ceo said
he's going to war to make sure this deal
goes through we had a will chamberlain
tweeted that elon's going to buy this
whether he wants to or not
yeah i was just realizing i was
referencing that same tweet by will he
he specified that twitter would likely
argue that one elon wasn't entitled to
the information he wanted which was like
how many bots are on the platform it
wasn't entitled and number two that if
he wasn't titled the failure to provide
the information was not a material
breach because the information isn't
relevant to any of the reps or
warranties in the agreement this is from
will chamberlain
but that's what makes me think it's it's
it's potentially 4d chess
i don't want to come out and be like oh
elon's so smart he's going to get them
now the dude may have just screwed up
yeah you know but
there's no way elon
he planned this out right he he he
released it on what 420
like this dude was like
calculating what he was doing yeah or
maybe not do you think he's always
playing the long game
i think people are comforted by thinking
elon has a plan you don't become a
billionaire
yeah and it's not just it's not just
that it's not hard to play the long game
right like we here at tim cast we're
playing the long game you know what i
mean yeah like i've got my vision board
that every day we wake up and ian and i
will put pictures of
celebrities no no but but you know we
have a generalized thought process of
like today we do this and if this works
the next day we do this and if this
works the next day we do this
so i have to imagine
when he was negotiating this contract he
had lawyers like he thought about what
could happen and this is not out of the
question this is one of these scenarios
he should have expected to occur so i
think whether he buys it or not i think
he knows what he's doing yeah yeah you
know my thing my trouble is with the
headline i don't want to say it's
misleading but it's really missing the
real problem with the deal
and we've all experienced this
when the whole elon situation was
announced did you get a huge uh
explosion engagement that's right okay
so and and the left and celebrities lost
a ton of engagement
hundreds it's it's
it was crazy
it was the day after the deal was
finalized right all of a sudden
prominent left-wing accounts lost tens
of thousands to hundreds of thousands of
followers
and people associated with the right
libertarians or you know the the
politically homeless what are they
called post-liberal yeah saw huge gains
i gained 100 000 followers in three days
people were getting unbanned right
something crazy happens yeah so my
theory is
uh the employees
abandoned the project
and that's in part of the deal was as
any with merger right you have to keep
your staff
on staff right because otherwise you're
buying the company the staff is a huge
part of these the people that run the
thing every day right
so i'm looking at the situation and i'm
like uh
maybe that's the big problem i don't
think it's the bots like i think elon
understands the bot game and i don't
think that's a deal breaker like you
know there's bots when you're dealing
with social media right
i think it's the the employees because
so many employees had a mass exodus and
then i i don't know what happened but i
think they turned the algorithm back on
because the engagement dropped again for
us but i think
whoever it is up there they're like okay
elon's gonna buy this thing let's hide
the algo right right and then like the
deal's off and it's like i turn the algo
back on and i think what you're saying
attributes to that is like the left huge
amount of engagement everybody else
engagement drops right and so the algo
favors that left wing opinion i'm
guessing but that's what i think the
deal really came what if it's what if
it's actually a bit more nefarious get a
little conspiratorial what if elon fully
intended to buy the platform
and then we've talked about this before
alex berenson who was banned do you know
him
he was covering a ton of the vaccine
stuff and he got he skeptical yeah he
got banned
filed a lawsuit won and was reinstated
and he said he's investigating
government involvement in twitter
censorship
what if elon was like hey i'm going to
buy this platform guys and then he goes
up to the meeting and then twitter says
as part of our disclosure process here's
our national security letter and he went
oh crap
and you can't say anything about it
because you got an nda yeah and now he's
like i don't want to buy this right well
look at what jack was saying when he was
telling people about dealing with boards
and all of that type of situations
dealing with vcs there's a lot jack was
saying um
between the lines you kind of had to
read when i don't know if you watched it
but he was arguing with some people
jack dorsey jack dorsey yeah he's
arguing with some people in the threads
and he was kind of insane like there's
some shaky things going on with twitter
with twitter and the government
uh he didn't allude to the government
you know i would say it's more like ngos
lizard people
yeah something something more realistic
like that yeah more realistic
elon shows up to the meeting and he's
like okay so can we finalize these
contracts and they're like uh yes but
one minute zorthon
we control twitter
actually i'm getting sworn in as the
president i'm sorry i shouldn't have
said zorthon he goes hillary
is a joke but but is
let's talk about the money is twitter a
good investment to me i don't see
twitter as being a good money player i
think it's a good power play right
because now you control this medium of
of conversation but to me i didn't see
it as a a money play like i wouldn't pay
44 billion for for for twitter that
seems like overvaluation i think he may
be walked into a trap yeah because
they're like oh by the way the reason we
do all this is because we have a
national security letter and the
government's got their gun to our back
and now you bought it it's on you it's
on you yeah and he's like oh crap yeah i
think this is this is a very powerful
tool twitter is a very powerful tool i
don't know how you monetize it but he
was talking about some a rumor
i don't know if you guys saw this he
wanted to turn it into like the wechat
of america where he wanted all the
payment systems and everything oh right
right you guys agree with that oh i
don't know about you what's wechat
firstly well in china like wechat right
i do have wechat i mostly made it as a
joke but i took it off my phone when i
saw that um
my phone was browsing fishing sites for
like 10 hours what
wait what
yeah you got hacked or something i mean
i don't know that if that means i was
hacked it stopped after i deleted it
[Laughter]
so what are you supposed to conclude
from that
um what is wechat
it's one of the big chinese social media
platforms beyond uh weibo right that's
the other one that's like the equivalent
of facebook um
and this one is sort of like whatsapp
um you have to get
endorsed or recommended by another user
who already has an account
um
so i had to like
reach out to somebody that i knew who
knew someone who had it
to
give me like a voucher to get on the
platform it's like very exclusive and
they don't want westerners on it
they're owned by 10 cent
uh i imagine this is just basically the
ccp such as a chinese company that's
yeah and they they really only want
chinese citizens on it
okay ideally but like like you're you're
you're i made it as a joke to be like
you can find me on wechat like as a joke
that's hilarious by the way um
that's hilarious
but but they but everything's on there
right like you pay i guess your mortgage
through this thing really
yeah yeah every like all your payments
atm i don't know don't get me the line
but if you all i saw as like the most
basic functions like posting a picture
posting something that looks like a
tweet yeah but we have a chinese citizen
like everything yeah i'm sure you can't
survive in china without wechat or
something so you're saying kind of like
facebook in a sense yeah there you go
but i guess i guess facebook you use
facebook to pay your mortgage right
there so you're talking about turning
into a payment system like a payment
services uh platform that's that's true
because the metaverse is blending uh
social media and payment services as
well as like all sorts of voting
services they're trying to blend like
yeah all these things together so you're
it's basically your life in the digital
space centralization yeah i want to
swipe right on that guy and send him 10
cents and that guy and send him five
dollars or whatever
yeah jack dorsey was trying to get he's
been integrating payment systems with
twitter while he was there yes well he
has what is it what does he do cash app
cash apps and square and then they want
bitcoin tips i think too or some was
all in bitcoin yeah you get tipped in
bitcoin thanks for checking out this
segment from the tim cast irl podcast
but if you want to check out the full
show live tune in monday through friday
at 8pm and if you want more special
access content head over to timcast.com
and become a member your membership
helps sustain this company keep our
journalists employed makes this show
happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
tim cast irl podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in monday through
friday at 8pm and we'll see you all
there
you